Lo que quiero hacer en este video es reflexionar
acerca de los orígenes del álgebra...
los orígenes del álgebra...
álgebra...
Y las ideas que asociamos ahora alrededor
del álgebra, tienen su origen en este libro,
sí, este libro que está aquí y viene de
la traducción del título de este libro,
que dice, "Compendio de Cálculo por
Compleción y Comparación""
y el autor es un matemático, que vivió en Baghdad, pienso que por ahí del siglo octavo o noveno,
digamos en el 820 de nuestra era
y la palabra álgebra es una palabra árabe
que corresponde a este título que le dio
a su libro, éste que vemos aquí.
La palabra álgebra quiere decir
recuperación y compleción...
Y hace referencia en su libro a una operación específica,
la de pasar cosas de un lado a otro en una ecuación.
Y podemos observarlo aquí en el título,
bueno, la verdad yo no soy experto en árabe
ni conozco el árabe...
conozco de algunos idiomas que han tomado
prestado ideas y palabras del árabe.
Aquí dice, "Al-Kitab", "Kitab" es libro, "al-mukhtasar" y aquí pienso que se refiere a compendio,
"fi hisab" y "hisab" tanto en
hindi como en urdu, es cálculo,
"al-gabr" y aquí está, la palabra clave, aquí está
la raíz de álgebra y la asociamos con compleción,
sí, con compleción...
"wa'l muqabala", ésta se refiere a igualar,
o sea aquí tenemos compleción e igualación.
Si quisiéramos traducir, bueno éste no es
un video de traducción de árabe,
diría algo así como, el libro, el compendio de cálculos, compleción e igualación.
Bueno, esta es una traducción un poco burda,
pero es el origen del álgebra.
Y este libro pues es importantísimo, muchos
lo ven como el libro en el cual el álgebra
fue tomando sus ideas principales,
sus ideas modernas...
La idea de ir manipulando ecuaciones, no nada
más de ir resolviendo casos por casos,
pero Al-Juarismi no fue el primero
en pensar en estas cosas.
Y para darnos una idea de dónde estaba
todo esto ocurriendo...
él estaba en Baghdad y bueno, pues es esta
parte que estamos mostrando aquí del mundo,
en donde han ocurrido muchísimas cosas
alrededor del álgebra...
voy a dibujar una línea del tiempo aquí,
para que vayamos ubicando las cosas...
así que esta es mi línea del tiempo y bueno,
seamos religiosos o no,  la mayoría de los eventos
que registramos en la actualidad están dados con respecto al nacimiento de Cristo
y habrá diferentes maneras de identificarlo
dependiendo si uno es religioso o no,
diríamos que de este lado está lo que llamamos de
nuestra era y desde el punto de vista religioso,
todo lo que es anterior, decimos que es antes de Cristo.
Bueno, pero son convenciones.
Así que más o menos, por aquí estará el
año 1000 de nuestra era,
por acá estará el 2000 de nuestra era y también tenemos por aquí, 1000 años antes de nuestra era
y 2000 años antes de nuestra era.
Y los primeros rastros...
bueno, debo de aclarar que me estoy refiriendo
a que si hiciéramos una investigación, encontraríamos
muchísimos más rastros...
yo me estoy refiriendo en términos generales
y reconociendo tanta gente que anduvo pensando
en estos conceptos del álgebra, pero los
registros más antiguos de los que tenemos
conocimiento, se remontan a la antigua Babilonia,
2000 años antes de la era cristiana o de nuestra era,
o sea, y estaría más o menos,
si por aquí y el registro son tablillas de arcilla,
donde se observa que había personas
ya trabajando con las ideas básicas del álgebra,
tal vez no usaban los mismos símbolos,
ni los mismos números
pero es claro que ya estaban trabajando con álgebra.
Y otra vez, esto estaba ocurriendo en la misma
parte del mundo, Babilonia estaba más o menos
por esta zona del mundo, Babilonia pues era
una ciudad importantísima, un lugar muy importante
entre 2 ríos y ahí es donde están los registros
que tenemos de que la gente estaba trabajando
de una manera real con el álgebra.
Y luego, este, vamos a dar un gran brinco,
pero podemos decir que las bases más importantes
del álgebra se dieron aquí 2000 años antes
de la era cristiana y luego nos vamos a mover
más o menos al año 280 de nuestra era y
entonces nos encontramos con este griego que
vivía en Alejandría, si mira, estamos hablando
de esta parte de Grecia, él vivía en Alejandría,
cuando era parte aún del imperio romano y
Alejandría está, más o menos,
en esta parte del mundo.
Y este caballero de nombre Diofanto...
Diofanto...
Si, no sé si lo estoy diciendo bien, pero
este caballero de nombre Diofanto, que muchas
veces se le llama, el padre del álgebra y
las cosas podríamos ponerlas un poco a debate,
¿qué tanto Al-Kwarizmi o Diofanto
son los padres del álgebra?
Pero mejor digamos que cada uno tiene sus
contribuciones únicas al desarrollo del álgebra.
Aunque en el caso de los historiadores occidentales, pues tal vez le den más crédito a Diofanto
como el padre del álgebra.
Y habrá otro grupo, el cual le atribuya a
Al-Kwarizmi pues el crédito de desarrollar el álgebra.
Y ahora, si viajamos en el tiempo más o menos al 580, tenemos otro personaje central en el álgebra,
de nombre, Brahmagrupta, éste es un
matemático hindú,
bueno, la verdad no sé en que parte de la India vivía este
personaje, pero de una manera burda estaba
en esta parte del mundo, pero hizo grandes
contribuciones al álgebra
y obviamente un tiempo después,
pues está Al-Kwarizmi,
quien sentó las bases de lo que ahora
conocemos como álgebra.
Y con justa razón se le denomina el padre
del álgebra, porque él fue el que...
planteó el álgebra desde el punto de vista
de la abstracción.
Mucho como utilizamos las matemáticas actualmente,
el punto de vista como trabajamos las
matemáticas en la actualidad.